what's up guys Melissa Sovereign here
with PAX East 2023 for the iron Lords
podcast and lordsofgaming.net I'm here
with Matthew over at the iterative
collective and we're looking at Sigil of
the Magi so Matthew tell us a little bit
about what Sigil of the Magi is well if
you're a gamer you know state is fire
you know into the bridge yes
it's a cross between both of them can
you say the sex and it breaches yes into
debris into the breach is one of my
favorite absolute favorite turn-based
roguelites yep let's talk let's talk
about magic so basically city of the
major is attack Builder yes we collect
cards as you play and each turn you get
a handout five six cards depending on
what cards you have okay and you can
play them to control three units on the
Playfield okay which is a grid
um basically you've got cards like
different attacks the cards correspond
to
um skills power-ups Buffs that kind of
stuff okay yep so is it is it a huge
Grid or is it a smaller grid because if
we look at something like into the
breaches much smaller yeah
small stages you control three
characters you're usually up against
maybe three to five other characters
okay
um and it's a roguelike so you choose
your own progression what path you take
um you could even stop at merchants or
fireplaces where you could hear your
characters and as a procedurally
generator yeah so the maps are the
positions of the maps are proceedingly
generated the type of playing field as
well it's a procedural and the enemies
you face the type of boss you face those
kind of things as well okay so story
wise what are we talking about probably
wise it's very well the story is in yeah
I'll be honest it's always thin okay but
basically your tree Adventures trying to
find uh the siju which there is a lost
years thousands of years ago basically
hunting for Hidden Treasure so when you
talk about turn based yes take me
through an encounter how many turns is
it one one move per turn you have three
moves per turn where you control the
three characters okay you can play as
many cards as
um you have Mana basically or like okay
so the modern term is the amount of cars
you can throw down for right okay so and
movement you can move the characters
around in their movement area okay and
attacks to enemies in range so
positioning is also a big part of it is
there OverWatch do you have an overhead
sort of looking downwards there is yes
all right so you see the characters you
see the enemies there's also information
about what what move the enemies will
make in the next turn these characters
they're targeting stuff like that so
it's very deep tactical gameplay okay so
let's talk about the gameplay a little
bit Yeah moment to moment how are we uh
how are we engaging are you saying you
have the three characters you have the
the three characters cards so like for
example if you have an Archer you're
playing an attack card or long shots for
example where you have to be a specific
distance away from the character yes
from the enemy and you have to position
yourself far away enough to hit the
enemy perfectly okay yep so tell us a
little bit about the engine what is it
built on that's built with Game Maker
two game maker too not a very common
engine these days yes
um but it's game maker because it's all
2D okay developed by solo developer
young
just young just young literally yeah uh
and tell us a little bit about when we
can expect to see the game at so the
game is already out in Early Access so
you can check it out today it's on Steam
and we're planning on a full launch
later this year a 1.0 version okay right
now there are two factions in the game
so there's six units that you can play
you can even mix them up yeah units from
each fraction but in the full launch
we're looking at one more faction okay
and they're truly rules for you to
explore what about other platforms um
platforms wise we're just looking for
the full launch and only after that we
will explore porting I think it's a
great game for the Nintendo search for
mobile platforms and we're looking and
we're exploring that at the moment okay
fantastic thank you so much for your
time Matthew this is Matthew from the
internet collection this is Sigil of the
Magi this is Lord Safran coming to you
live from Praxis 2023 for the iron Lords
podcast and Lords of gaming.net yep